yo let's ask not Indians to name five
Indians oh good it is good right they
can't do it well we're going living
Indians but Mohan Singh Tom Bonney
brothers no [ __ ] like that man why did
he give you as ignorant as you yeah you
actually expect him to stop learning yes
yeah you got meal for everybody I don't
even think you need to know something if
it's not gonna make you my honestly
believe that every Union believes that
noise watch this watch it chug beer he's
the best what was your GPA in college
3.8 bro only that ys what's the capital
of your on la boom do you know the
counter on why would i know some goofy
[ __ ] like that Tehran cage ja j weezy so
easy right here that's not weird people
know everything about every culture is a
weird it's an amazing thing we're all
human we're made up the same thing too
why don't you understand that a good so
gay bro that is not getting its
sensitive listen here's hold on it
wouldn't be creepy if I knew everything
about like Ireland wouldn't any kind of
creepy like I just know everything about
shamrocks in a green beer and kilton and
William Wallace sphere balls of Scotland
was exactly same case what is that right
here what is wrong with cultures
assimilating everything why do you think
I she don't need for using words like a
semi lady I don't even know what that
means I don't cover why don't you see
why he always took some case you know
we're gonna guys not always okay toccata
I I know you're like 116th Comanche is
so weird wait high school look man I
understand you ruining all the Indian
names I do but how do you butcher case
Russell ki SE spells case
my real name is Kaiser assault case is
my nickname so what does that make you
the spanish version and a phone what Oh
pregnant thankfully later now a minute
so you're really not white no then why
did you let me [ __ ] on even be a white
thought you were jealous cuz I'm lighter
than you well [ __ ] i am now John Chandra
shun shun under shaker